هذه كيت الرائعة حقًا
وتتحدث حقًا عن اليأس والغضب
الذي يشعر به الكثير من الناس في إسرائيل
أه عندما يتعلق الأمر بالرهائن الذين ما
زالوا محتجزين في غزة والجهود
أو عدم وجودها التي تقولها
الحكومة من أجل  أطلقوا سراحهم فهذا الشريط
الذي حصلت عليه أه منفذ الأخبار الإسرائيلي
الرطب هو أه تسجيل صوتي
لاجتماع بين أه الرهائن
أنفسهم وعائلاتهم أه مع
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو أه
يتهمونه باللعب بالسياسة على تقديم
السياسة على تحرير ال
الرهائن يقولون إن
أجهزة المخابرات في إسرائيل لم يكن لديها
فكرة جيدة عن مكان احتجاز الرهائن
ويقولون إن الحملة العسكرية الإسرائيلية
حتى أنها عرضت للخطر وأصابت
بعض الرهائن. أريد تشغيل
مقطع لإحدى النساء في  في هذا اللقاء
كانت هي نفسها رهينة مع
أطفالها وتم إطلاق سراحهم ولكن زوجها لا
يزال في الداخل، وتقول إنه لم يكن أحد
يفعل أي شيء لهم، كما تقول وأن
القصف الإسرائيلي أصابهم بالفعل،
استمعوا،
وسوف تعيدون لهم كل شيء، ولن
ينتظروا  50 يومًا لن ينتظروا
عامًا آخر لأنك تدعي أنهم أقوياء بما فيه
الكفاية، ليس لديك معلومات،
ليس لديك معلومات، حقيقة أننا
تعرضنا للقصف، حقيقة أنه لا أحد يعرف
أي شيء عن مكان
وجودنا، لذلك طالب الرهينة السابق
نتنياهو بأن يرحل.  أخرج بقية
الرهائن الآن عند نقطة ما،
وفقًا لهذا التسجيل،
بدأ الناس يصرخون بالعار على الشبكة،
ودافع نتنياهو عن العمل العسكري
قائلاً إن
العمليات العسكرية والضغط العسكري هو الذي
أدى إلى إطلاق سراح الرهائن الأولي
واستمر في ذلك.  ليقولوا أن المزيد من
الضغط العسكري سيساعد في الواقع على إخراج بقية
الرهائن أه كيت الحقيقة
تبقى أن ما يقل قليلا عن 140 رهينة 138
على وجه التحديد ما زالوا في قطاع غزة
وهناك الكثير من الغضب الموجه ضد
حكومة نتنياهو التي يعتقدون أنها
وأنهم يقولون إن حكومة نتنياهو
لا تفعل ما يكفي لإعادتهم إلى وطنهم
كيت